from different worlds.
And now is a product of the love that never
should have been kicked unite our wealth one day.
My son of the land.
And the son of the Seas.
My mother always knew you were special.
You are part of something deeper.
You are the bridge. Between land and sea.
Take your rightful place. Is King?
We're getting close now. Dyna thirst.
There's no way Lansing for this far inland.
Check this place out. This is bad.
It's real.
Nothing.
Of course, it's not working it's been sitting here collecting
dust since before the Sahara was a desert for the
Sahara was a desert.
Let's see you do your best thinking when you're not
thinking at all right now hold stone?
What are you doing? Need water.
Me the closest source.
Show off.
You could've just peed on it.
In this Trident resides the power.
Of Atlantis.
If you sync my power.
Journey beyond the edge of the world to the hidden
see.
In the wrong hands, it would bring destruction.
But in the hands of the Trulia.
It would unite all our kingdoms.
Above and below.
Family. What should we have written it down first I
memorized it didn't you Oh yeah?
What did you say something something Trident.
At least as awakening. The time has come.
For Atlantis to rise again.
Here. How are you?
That was awesome.
The war is coming to the surface.
You are not going to win this.
Billions will die unless you help us.
No leader. Not King. Dentist is always had it came
now,
I need something more.
Or it could be greater than a King.
A hero.